you're good man charlie brown the
peanuts movie you know I got to be
honest I debated even giving a review or
my thoughts on this cuz i'm not sure
what else there is to say besides it's
good i mean it's it's exactly what you
want a Charlie Brown movie to be if you
grew up on the comic strip or more
likely grew up on the cartoons and the
specials this is that it is a wonderful
terrific spot on recreation of that from
the look to the voices to the moments
that we get it is true to the heart of
this not a huge surprise given that
certain members of the shoals family
Charles Scholes being the original
creator and the writer of the comic
strip they they were involved in the
making of this and in the writing of
this and it honors everything about
Charlie Brown and Snoopy and the rest of
this cast just spot-on terrific I think
the most admirable thing about this is
that it resists the temptation to go too
big so many times when you get an
adaptation of something that had been
you know I just need TV show sound of
not kind of nice pleasant smaller key
they have to make it big they have to
make it huge they have to make it
cinematic and sometimes that works but
the very nature of peanuts kind of
resist that like it's supposed to be
low-key and they don't lose sight of
that I suppose purists might argue that
sort of the the Red Baron fantasy
sequences with Snoopy do get a little
too big because instead of just Snoopy
on his doghouse just imagining all of it
and just flashing lights we actually see
what he's imagining so those do turn a
bit into action set-pieces I do think
that maybe is a little much but honestly
it's kind of offset by the fact that he
himself is still just sitting on a
doghouse and we get flashes every now
and then to what he's actually doing in
the real world you know compared to what
he is imagining going on and that helps
that from being just a little bit too
much but again as I said purists might
not go for that aspect but other than
that it's just so right they don't try
and
fix it because peanuts is not broken it
never was the music is what you remember
the voices are what you remember the
characters the animation I when I first
heard that this was going to be a cgi
animated film I was furious I'm like why
would you ever take the wonderful
simplicity of Schultz's drawings and do
that as 3d animation what's the point I
you know what they pulled it off they
managed to give us things with 3d that
I'm like okay that's actually adding
something and when I say 3d I don't mean
3d screening I just mean you know 3d
computer modeling because I saw the
thing in 2d but it works and it's
wonderful they take advantage of that
but we never lose the purity and the
simplicity of the designs of these
characters and I'm stunned that they
were able to pull that off so absolutely
hats off for that they don't try and
modernize it it's still as timeless as
you always remember it nobody busts out
a smartphone nobody's sitting on a
computer they're playing hockey they're
going to school they're trying to fly
kites Lucy's psychiatry advice still
only costs a nickel it's the sort of
thing that I feel we don't get often
enough these days when it comes to
adapting something to the big screen
which is nobody's trying to fix it that
just seems to happen so often that they
take something yo either they're
remaking an older movie or they're
taking a comic book or a novel or
whatever and they're changing things
like oh we can do it better but there
was nothing wrong with it in the first
place in this movie knows there's
nothing wrong with peanuts don't mess
with it that was really this movie's
only job don't screw it up and they
didn't I really don't think there was
too much more to say besides that if you
like Charlie Brown specials at all go
and see this it will delight you so have
you seen the peanuts movie if you have
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it as for me I'll be
back as soon as I can get my next fix